The
useful starting point is not a
battlefield legend but an institution.
In 1882,
Jigoro Kano
established the Kodokan.
That date does not mean
every
older jujutsu practice vanished overnight.
It marks the point at which Kano's
system gained a durable home,
a
teaching structure,
and an identity.
That distinction changes the question we are
asking.
Instead of looking for a
single ancient technique that somehow
travelled
unchanged into Brazil,
we can follow a system as it
acquires schools, teachers, rules, and
public meaning.
The date is an anchor in the
record,
not a
magical beginning for every practice that later
received the name
jiu-jitsu.
Kodokan judo
was already a transformation.
Kano drew from multiple jujutsu schools,
selected and reorganized techniques, and connected practice
to
a broader educational program.
So the story begins with adaptation inside
Japan,
before the
art
ever
reaches Brazil.
A
system is not only a
list of movements. It is also
a way of deciding what should be
taught,
how students should practice, what counts as
progress,
and which ideas deserve to travel with
the
exercise.
When later observers describe judo or jiu-jitsu,
they may be describing different portions of
that
larger project.
Keeping the transformation visible prevents us from
mistaking a later label for an unchanged
original.
Kano's project was larger than a catalog
of fighting moves.
Institutional histories emphasize education,
disciplined practice, efficient use of
energy, and mutual benefit.
Those ideas
matter
because later travelers could carry techniques,
sporting rules, professional contests,
or
educational
ideals in different proportions.
The same practice could look different when
it entered a school,
a
theater,
challenge match,
or a community of immigrants.
This is why a history of Brazilian
jiu-jitsu
cannot be reduced to asking who knew
which move first.
We also have to
ask what the practice was being used
for, who was teaching it,
and what the surrounding institution rewarded.
Terminology
was not settled.
Contemporary and retrospective sources use judo,
jiu-jitsu,
Kano jiu-jitsu,
and related spellings in overlapping ways.
Accounts differ about what each public label
implied,
so this episode follows documented people and
practices instead of treating a
name as a perfectly stable technical system.
That caution is
not a footnote.
Public names travel through advertisements, demonstrations, newspapers,
translations, and
later memories.
A
word can be
used to sell an exhibition,
identify a teacher,
describe a lineage,
or summarize a ruleset.
The label tells us what someone called
the practice;
it does not automatically tell us that
every participant understood the practice in exactly
the same way.
Maeda was important, but he did not
enter an empty
landscape.
Scholarship documents Japanese jiu-jitsu
demonstrations and
contests in Brazil
before his arrival,
including a
highly publicized
1909 encounter in Rio.
That earlier presence complicates any claim that
Brazilian grappling history begins on
one day in 1914.
It also
gives the audience a better kind of
origin
story.
Before the famous names become connected,
there are public events,
competing descriptions,
and people whose roles are harder to
preserve in a simplified narrative.
The record asks
us to see Brazil as a place
where martial practices were already being displayed,
discussed, and interpreted.
The title of first teacher is disputed.
Some accounts foreground Maeda and Satake;
others identify
earlier
Japanese practitioners or distinguish
public performers from immigrant-community instruction.
The evidence is
mixed,
and a single winner would create more
certainty than the sources allow.
That does not make the history unknowable.
It tells us which statements need qualification.
We can describe a growing
field of Japanese martial practice in Brazil
without pretending that every demonstration was a
school, or that every performer held the
same teaching role.
A careful documentary keeps the question
open when the sources keep it open.
The record
does support a major transition in 1914.
Maeda and Soishiro Satake entered Brazil with
other Japanese martial artists after travelling through
the Americas.
They were not simply
missionaries following a modern curriculum;
public demonstrations and professional contests were part
of the network that carried their practice.
Their movement across borders
matters because it makes transmission physical and
social.
People carried skills,
names,
reputations, performance habits, and business arrangements.
What arrived in Brazil was therefore
not a sealed package labelled Brazilian jiu-jitsu.
It was a set of practices moving
through a changing international circuit,
ready to be adapted again.
By 1915,
the troupe was in Belém,
a
city shaped by the Amazon rubber economy
and a cosmopolitan entertainment circuit.
Theaters,
demonstrations,
challenges, and
advertised lessons
put Japanese grappling in front of
audiences who encountered it as
education,
spectacle, and practical combat at the same
time.
Belém is
more than a pin
on a migration map.
It is a setting that helps explain
why a practice could change as it
moved.
The audience,
venue,
local economy, and promise
made by an instructor all influenced what
was visible.
The same art could be presented as
disciplined study in
one room
and
as a public test in another.
That context
shaped what students could receive.
Cairus describes Maeda's Brazilian teaching alongside professional
wrestling and prizefighting,
with less emphasis on the full Kodokan
pedagogical structure.
This does not prove a
secret combat system.
It shows why
techniques,
labels, and teaching methods could shift as
they moved.
A
public challenge rewards one kind of explanation;
a
regular class rewards another.
A performer must demonstrate quickly,
while a teacher may build habits over
time.
Treating those settings as interchangeable creates a
false mystery.
Treating them as different environments gives us
a practical explanation for why
later accounts do
not line up perfectly.
Accounts differ on the clean version of
the handoff.
The evidence places Carlos Gracie in the
Belém training network associated with Maeda,
while scholarship also
identifies senior student Jacyntho
Ferro and warns against treating later lineage
tradition as a complete classroom record.
We can say there was transmission;
we should qualify its exact shape.
The responsible claim is narrower than the
familiar legend and stronger
because of that restraint.
It recognizes Carlos as part of an
important network without erasing the people,
settings, and uncertainties that the surviving scholarship
places around the relationship.
Jacyntho
Ferro matters because a network is
not a single arrow on a family
tree.
Cairus identifies him as a senior local
student
who taught within Maeda's circle.
Including that role does not erase Carlos
Gracie;
it prevents the visual grammar of
lineage from deleting the intermediaries the scholarship
names.
Teaching networks are made of relationships that
do not always fit a clean diagram.
A student can become an instructor,
a
local teacher can carry practice into
another community,
and later memory can compress several stages
into
one famous connection.
The historical task is to
restore those stages where the evidence allows
it.
Brazilian development also
extended beyond the best-known
Rio lineage.
Studies of Brazilian judo
identify immigrant teachers, professional fighters, and community
networks that spread related practices through different
regions.
That wider field is why the next
episode treats forgotten branches as
research questions
rather than decorative side notes.
The point is not to replace one
heroic family with a different heroic
list.
It is to change the shape of
the explanation.
A
national tradition can emerge from
overlapping communities,
and a later public identity can become
dominant without being the only path by
which practice travelled.
The Brazilian identity of the art was
not finished in Belém.
Scholarship locates a
major phase of
reinvention in the 1930s,
when public performances,
institutions, promotion, and nationalism
helped distinguish a Brazilian combat sport from
Japanese immigrant traditions
and from
other local fighting practices.
Reinvention means more than changing a technique.
It can change the audience,
the rules,
the stories attached to the practice,
and the institutions that preserve it.
This is where a travelling practice becomes
a public identity.
The history is no
longer only about arrival;
it is about selection,
promotion,
memory,
and the power to define what counts
as Brazilian. The most accurate conclusion is
also the more interesting one.
Kano's system was an adaptation;
international travel changed its setting and emphasis;
Brazil already contained competing practices and communities;
and
later institutions
remade the public identity again.
Brazilian jiu-jitsu was not copied once.
It was transformed repeatedly.
That conclusion is not an attempt to
make the history less dramatic.
It gives the drama more places to
live: in institutions, ships, theaters, classrooms, challenges,
immigrant communities,
and the choices later promoters made about
which connections to
remember.
Explore the people, places, and sources behind
jiu-jitsu at NationalBJJRegistry.com.